alors comment est-ce qu'on peut
expliquer pierre-jean honnêtement un tel
succès parce que c'est un phénomène et
surtout c'est un phénomène a plus la
semos à ce que ça plaît à tout le monde
même les jeunes des gamins mon
bégaiement monfils battu voilà il ay là
à 15 ans immédiat je ne peux pas rater
affaire ben 5% de part d'audience sur
les 2 5%
je suis allé voir chantal goya la
semaine dernière et je me suis pris pour
elle parce que tous les gamins venait me
faire des demandes et des photos j'avais
remplacé chantal ma carrière et par une
partie ça y est je l'aï pas pire aux
mets dans sa marche et ça marche en
france mais ça marche en belgique ça
marche ça marche surtout ça marche
partout en israël au liban par tous là
on parle de 2 millions et ses 4 5 6
millions par jour de gens qui regardent
l'émission assez colossal et les
problèmes fonctionne également travaillé
on a fait une émission spéciale au mois
de décembre on a cartonné
alors moi j'aimerais concombre expliqué
harold comment vous sélectionnez les
objets parce que c'est se pose qui est
un cas ci alors c'est un casting
d'objets ou un casting de propriétaires
d'objets et ben c'est un casting dauger
absous l'accord absolument et donc moi
j'ai déjà de la production en amont
c'est vrai que je suis dans les bureaux
de la production et je vois toutes les
candidatures de nos futurs vendeurs il
ya 150 candidatures par jour que gens
qui postulent pour pour vendre des
affaires conclut donc je regarde les
photos et jeux et je le redis très
rapidement si c'est intéressant ou non
ensuite le casting va se charger de
faire venir les candidats alors on va
s'intéresser à la plus grosse vente
on a les images ça a fait beaucoup
parler puisqu'il s'agissait daruda d'un
rebond alors à la plus grosse vente
c'est un bon père jean ggt voir sur
internet les différentes ventes de rodin
j'ai pas trouvé un rodin à moins de cent
cinquante mille euros alors que vous
avez fait une très bonne affaire et vous
avez ce gros vous ne répondez après a
été fondue dans les fonderies
bruxelloise qui avait un contrat avec
rodin l'a300 1500 1800 2003-2004 3500
euros 4402 103-105 1800 civils 6500
lithié 7100 à 7500 cherlin avec le lycée
c'était combien pour vous c'était 7107
900 pourquoi vous aimeriez le vendre à
7100 à pierre-jean haut lieu pour une
raison particulière c'est que lui veut
la garder le geste me paraît plus noble
je me sens bien non honnêtement c'est un
rodin mais c'est un rôdeur de loin quoi
c'est alors en fait c'est un rôdeur de
près mais en fait pourquoi cette somme
en fait rodin a eu deux carrés de 2,2
deux périodes dans sa vie a pris d'elle
sa période de jeunesse oui travailler
carrier belleuse et c'est à rodin de
cette période
malheureusement on dirait d'erding de
cette période là il va le pas très cher
d'ailleurs de parole même ses 2100
l'argent mais c'est pas 100 mais j'ai
une question parce que je suis moi je ne
vends rien je crois à l'antenne on
pouvait pas monter montrait forcément du
liquide et dans cette émission de la
demie l'euro c'est un chèque
oui on donne un chèque à partir de
minéraux d'accord et il paraît que vous
vous échanger des billets quand vous
n'êtes pas et d'oseille entre les uns et
les autres
en coulisses on va dire il faut être
sans balle ou 200 euros mais on sait
quand on sera prêt mais parce que on a
pensé pas vous dois payer l'appui
imagine la joie la journée on fait quand
même quatre émissions ou cinq émissions
par jour on est pas on n'est pas des
coffres forts en bulles en quoi enfin en
plus moi du liquide tu veux te remercie
mon chef
[Rires]
on a je t'achète même pas un poster de
line renaud il semble donc donc de temps
à autre la pratique vise la production
ils ont un peu d'argent mais quand on
dépasse là c'est bien ces derniers temps
ça monte en qualité on a vraiment des
objets j'ai acheté il ya quelques
quelques semaines quelques temps une
amphore un enfant de 2200 ans j'ai
acheté une la flamme olympique des jeux
olympiques de londres ont passé l'argent
tu vois c'est des trucs mais j'aimerais
savoir tout ce que vous achetez vous le
revendez oumma rien du tout vous gardez
pour vous dans ma chambre
bien qu'ayant concurrents sur ses traits
à la maison sur m6 lie très long
ça marche ça marche mal et d'or comme
vous dans l'émission il ya eu un
phénomène alors c'était pas un rodin
sauf que les ya un monsieur qui veut
acheter un miroir il avait acheté 150
euros regardez combien il a été adjugé
aux enchères
franchement c'est jamais en mode saas
pour le show il téléphone par rhys hill
58000 58 58 euros pour ce superbe miroir
de line vautrin cinq ans
tu es 1000 euros s'est vu à 58 milles
euros je vais adjugé sans regrets dans
la salle
j'ai 58 ans ça fait acheter 150 euros
par hasard là c'est du cinquante humain
[Musique]
parce que vous avez un flair
tant que nous voyons disney oui vous
aussi là faut qu'on m'explique
est-ce que harold soit soyez comment
c'est possible d'acheter quelque chose
150 euros et de le revendre sa grande
tournée de la chose comme ça c'est plus
donnée sur la teneur des gens qui se
lèvent tôt le matin qui ont chiné à 6
heures du matin au cul du camion comme
on dit et il peut faire des trouvailles
ça arrive ça arrive c'est moi j'ai
acheté à quelques années à drouot ya
longtemps les démos chez vous il ya
vingt ans j'ai acheté à drouot à moto
grave c'était une copie du testament de
napoléon
encore oui encore décidément c'est bono
maniaque et puis ya quelques années
j'avais besoin de l'argent je les ai
revendues j'ai vendu 350 mille euros
vous êtes un bon parent vous êtes à mon
parti je suis j'aimerais juste qu'on me
dit la rolls si dans l'histoire on a des
aiguillages c'est pas quelqu'un qui a
retrouvé une toile de maître dans une
tendance dans une cave ou dans un
grenier c'est arrivé ça ou pas oui on a
déjà entendu des histoires comme ça et
aux états unis
quelqu'un qui avait acheté un claude
monet dans une brocante il l'appelait je
sais plus une dizaine de dollars et il
hilare leur idole
le dernier leonard de vinci le dernier
léonard-de-vinci café 450 millions de
dollars
il a été trouvé dans une brocante aux
états unis a 50 ans ah ouais il payé 200
dollars
cherry demain on va la brocante à 6h
bien j'ai toujours que vous jouez à
grands comptes et des fous regarder mais
tous regardés